[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: I am super
excited to have
Clara Hemphill, founder of
Inside Schools, here with us
today.
She's a font of knowledge,
and it's exciting.
So just a little bit about
Clara so you know who she is.
She leads the Center of New
York City Affairs policy work
on economic segregation
of the city's schools,
examining why there are schools
with high concentrations
of poverty even in
mixed-income neighborhoods.
The "New York Times" called
her three books designed
to help parents choose
good elementary, middle,
and high schools
for their children
the most definitive guides
to the city's schools.
And "New York"
magazine called her one
of the 200 most influential
New Yorkers for her work
in empowering parents.
Previously as a reporter
and editorial writer
for New York "Newsday," she
shared the Pulitzer Prize
for local reporting.
"New York" magazine called her
writing on the homeless worthy
of Dickens.
She was a foreign correspondent
for the Associated Press
and a producer for CBS
News based in Rome.
She has two children,
both now grown,
and they both attended New
York City public schools
from kindergarten
through high school.
So please join me in welcoming
Clara Hemphill to talk
about the public
schools and navigating
the very segregated and
ridiculously complex
New York City school system.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
CLARA HEMPHILL: Thank you.
I'm really glad to be here.
I wrote the first edition
of this book 20 years ago
when my children
were three and one.
They're now all grown up.
And I thought, gee, I can
figure out this bureaucracy.
I was a foreign
correspondent in Rome.
I covered the Vatican,
which I thought
was the most secretive
bureaucracy on the planet.
And then I realized
the Board of Education
is even more
secretive and complex.
So I thought if I had
trouble, other people
might have trouble too.
And I started writing
the books then.
A couple years later, we set
up the Inside Schools website.
And we just released the fourth
edition of the "New York City's
Best Public Pre-K and Elementary
Schools" on sale in the back.
I hope you buy it.
Thanks very much.
Why should you
choose public school?
Why do public schools matter?
And one of the things that
the last election showed us,
the national elections, is how
divided we are as a country.
And public schools,
when they work,
have the ability to
bring us together,
to help us understand
one another.
And we need the public
schools now more than ever.
This picture here is
an example of a school
that I think brings
people together.
It's Dos Puentes in
Washington Heights.
If you know Washington Heights,
on the east side of Broadway
is mostly Dominican
Spanish-speaking kids.
On the west side is mostly
English-speaking kids.
Dos Puentes brings
these kids together
in a dual-language program,
where they speak English
half the time and they
speak Spanish half the time.
And it's a really
lovely, lovely school
and an example of how
children can learn together.
One of the things I like
about it is that the parents'
meetings are given--
sometimes they're
given in Spanish with
English translation,
and sometimes they're
given in English
with Spanish translation.
And one of the things I liked
about going to that school
was having the experience
of being somebody
who didn't understand the
language that was spoken
and had to have the translation.
So that's one of the schools in
the book that I can recommend.
Public schools are just
about the only place
besides jury duty
and the subways
where people of different races,
incomes, and backgrounds mix.
This is Ella Baker
School on the Upper East
Side, which is open
to children by lottery
from all five Boroughs.
So it's not a zoned school.
It's a city-wide school.
And the great education
philosopher John Dewey,
at the turn of the
last century, wrote
that "schools should
teach children
to be social beings
trained for leadership
as well as obedience, trained
so they can be voting citizens
in a multi-ethnic democracy,
not passive subjects.
"Teachings them to be social
beings without letting them
mingle with other
children," Dewey wrote,
is like teaching them
to swim without letting
them go in the water.
I remember talking
to a Jewish father
some time ago who was
choosing between a Jewish day
school and a public school.
And I told him,
yes, I understand
you want your child to
learn about your religious
traditions, Hebrew.
Your values are very
important to you.
But if you send your
child to public school,
I guarantee he will meet
at least one child who
celebrates Ramadan.
And a child who
celebrates Ramadan
will meet at least
one child who--
he interrupted me.
He said, yeah, I get the idea.
I get the point.
And that clinched
the deal for him.
This is PS 75 on the
Upper West Side, which
serves both Columbia
University professors' children
but also children who live
in public housing nearby.
A lot of the schools in the book
are ordinary zoned neighborhood
schools, no special application.
You just sign your child up.
This is PS 180 in Harlem.
In some ways, it's
an ordinary school.
Test scores are nothing special.
It's just sort of
an ordinary school.
But a mother told
me, I feel like I'm
part of a community and
a neighborhood in a way
that I never expected--
the pleasure of making friends
with other parents, sharing
babysitters and
after-school pickups,
even sharing holiday meals.
So I live on the
Upper East Side,
and I never felt I really
lived in the neighborhood
until I had children and sent
them to the public schools.
And there's something about
sharing the responsibilities
of parenthood with other
people in the neighborhood that
really makes you feel like
you belong in a neighborhood.
Now I know some of
you will say, oh,
that's all very well
and good for you.
You live on the Upper East Side.
But what if you live in the
Bronx or in central Brooklyn?
One of the questions I got ahead
of time for this talk was--
this is a quote from one of you.
"Public school is not a viable
option for every New Yorker."
This parent was zoned for
133 in District 5 in Harlem.
"I cannot in good conscience
send my children to my zoned
school.
Charter is also not
an option if you're
against rote memorization and
some other very regimented
tactics they use
to teach students."
It's true that there
aren't as many good schools
in poor and working-class
neighborhoods
as there are in
rich neighborhoods.
And racial and
economic segregation
is a reality, as
those of you who
were at Nikole Hannah-Jones'
talk some time ago remember.
But in researching
the book, we found
good schools in every one of
the city's 32 school districts,
not as many as we'd
like, but at least a few.
And we found some
pleasant surprises.
You don't have to live on Park
Avenue to find a good school.
I also want to say that
not all the charter
schools are rigid places
where children are
expected to act like robots.
There are some
progressive schools,
where children learn through
exploration and play.
And not all the charter
schools are the same, just
the way all the ordinary public
schools are not the same.
What about segregation?
It's true, and it's really
the shame of our city.
But even predominantly white
schools or predominantly Asian
schools or predominantly
black and Latino
schools still have lots
of different religions,
lots of different languages.
I was at PS 189 in Crown Heights
the other day in Brooklyn.
It's 97% black and
Latino, but the children
speak Spanish, English, creole.
There's even some
Chinese kids there.
There's a range of incomes.
There's a pediatrician.
There's a cab driver,
a home health aide.
It's a school that
has served generations
of parents in Crown Heights.
And they have dual language
programs where children
can learn Spanish and creole.
They even learn Latin.
So that's a school
which in some ways
is indeed highly segregated
and in other ways is diverse.
I remember going to an all
black school in Brooklyn
and asking the kids what
they liked about it.
And they said, oh, I
love the diversity.
And I said, what do you mean?
And they said, oh, we have
kids from every single island
in the Caribbean.
Another reason to
choose a public school
is kids need parents
who aren't stressed out.
Commuting time really matters.
If you're trying to decide
between a great school 20
blocks away and a pretty good
school across the street,
I would choose the
one across the street.
Another question is, if
you're working 60 hours a week
to pay private school
tuition, maybe you're
better off sending your
child to public school.
If working part time means you
can go on an occasional field
trip, volunteer
at the school, you
may enjoy being with
your child, and that time
can be very important.
I also want to point out
that education is not
just what you have from 9:00
AM to 3:00 PM 180 days a year.
Just living in the
city of New York
gives you access to resources
that people elsewhere
don't have, the Natural
History Museum, the Bronx Zoo.
My children danced with the
National Dance Institute.
There are huge
numbers of resources
that you can take advantage of
just by living in the school.
Of course the argument
about the 60 hours a week
may work the other way.
If you're already working--
I realized I'm talking
to Googlers here.
If you're already
working 60 hours a week,
you may want to choose private
because you don't have to be
on top of everything at school.
But what my point is is
consider your own convenience
and your own levels of stress
when you're deciding on school.
The children are made
of rubber, and they
can adapt to lots of
different situations.
Another thing I
want you to remember
is that no school is perfect.
As a parent, you have to
decide what you can live with,
what you can supplement at home.
There's some things you can fix,
and there's some things that
you can't.
You certainly don't want to
send your child to a school
where there's lots of bullying,
or where the adults yell
at the children, or where
teachers have low expectations
and the children are overwhelmed
by the problems of poverty.
My children's school had
physical education just one day
a week.
So what did we do?
We supplemented with West
Side Soccer League, which
is a volunteer, moms and dads
will coach kids on the weekend.
They take up most
of the park space
in the city on the weekend.
You've probably seen them.
If there's not
enough math drill,
you can have flashcards at home.
If there's not a
foreign language,
you can take the
whole family to France
for three months for the price
of private school tuition.
It also depends on your child.
Some children are
like-- a nursery school
teacher described this to me.
Some children are
like dandelions.
They're robust, and they can
flourish in lots of places.
Others are more like orchids.
They're delicate, and they need
just the right temperature.
Some schools do a good job with
children with special needs.
Others do not.
So it depends a little bit
on your own family situation
and on the what
your child is like.
The most important thing,
a friend once told me,
is to find a school
that doesn't kill
your child's natural curiosity.
A lot of what children
learn in the early years
is not-- particularly
in kindergarten,
it's not cognitive.
It's social, learning how to
sit in a circle, how to share,
how to develop
independence, things
like how to tie your own shoes.
The tone and climate
of a school may
be more important than
the children's scores
on standardized tests.
Oh, and the scores, by the way,
tell you where a school's been.
It doesn't tell you necessarily
where a school is going.
A school that's promising
and on its way up
may provide a better
experience for your child
than a complacent,
well-established school that's
coasting on its reputation.
So that's my pitch
on why public.
Now I'm going to give
you the sort of the nuts
and bolts of how to navigate
the New York City public school
system.
The good news is that all
four-year-olds are guaranteed
a seat in pre-kindergarten.
The bad news is it may not
be in the school closest
to your home.
If you're willing
to travel a bit,
you'll definitely get a spot.
The applications
open in mid-January.
The deadlines are at
the end of February.
But if you're looking for
a school for your child
this fall, take heart.
Seats open up in the
spring and the summer.
For your child to
be eligible, he
needs to have his fourth
birthday by December 31.
That means, and say if
he has a fall birthday,
he'll actually start
pre-kindergarten
when he's three.
de Blasio has also
promised that he's
going to have
pre-pre-kindergarten
for three-year-olds.
They're going to start in two
high-poverty districts, one
in the South Bronx and one in
central Brooklyn in the fall.
They haven't got money
for anything else,
so I think asking the
federal government
and the state for extra money
right now is probably not
going to happen.
But we do have pre-K
for four-year-olds.
Not all of the
pre-kindergarten classes
are in ordinary public schools.
In fact, most of them
are housed in child care
centers or private nursery
schools or religious schools.
You can see the pie chart here.
The cities also opened what
they call pre-K centers.
These are standalone
schools that your child
will attend for just one year.
We list some of our
favorites in the book.
It's certainly a
good idea to visit,
but most of the programs
we visit are pretty good.
So that's pre-K.
Elementary, this is where
the big kid school begins.
And this is when
you're five years old,
if you are five
before December 31,
you're entitled to start
school in that September.
So for the pre-K, you're
guaranteed a seat someplace,
but not necessarily in your
zoned neighborhood school.
In fact, most of
you will not have
a seat in your zoned
neighborhood school.
Some of them just have
18 seats for pre-K
and 125 seats for kindergarten.
So most of you are
going to have to look
outside of your zoned public
school for pre-kindergarten.
However, for elementary
school, most of you
have a zoned elementary
school, and your child
is guaranteed admission there.
One of the questions that
you gave me in advance
was about wait lists.
There are some schools
have wait lists.
But honestly, almost all
of the wait lists clear.
They ask parents to sign
up early, and many do.
And they tell you that you're
on a wait list in March.
But by September,
an awful lot of kids
have either moved
out of the city,
or chosen a private
school, or gone
into a gifted and
talented program.
So I would not worry
about-- there's
a couple of schools that have
serious wait lists in Sunset
Park, a couple in Queens.
But by and large, it's
not going to be a problem.
The timeline is in--
do I have another
slide for this?
Nope, this is the districts.
The timeline is you
apply in November
if you want your
child to be considered
for a gifted program.
I'm not a big fan
of gifted education,
but if your zoned neighborhood
school isn't adequate,
it's certainly an option
that you should consider.
The testing for children
for the gifted program
is in January and February.
And by January, then you submit
applications for other schools.
Honestly the deadline
is way too early.
Most people in the city
don't know in January
what they're going to
be doing in September,
and they almost
always extend it.
By the end of March,
you'll find out
where your child's
been assigned.
If you're interested
in charter schools,
the deadline is April 1.
And then in April, you find
out if your children-- you
know what?
I'm making this too complicated.
Read the book.
Ask questions afterwards.
I can see that the eyes
are getting a little bit
panic-stricken here.
Zone maps.
Sorry.
OK, the city is divided
into 32 districts.
One of the questions was, why
are the districts so weird?
Why don't they just
make them according
to the voting districts?
The answer is buried in history.
The districts were
set up in 1969
as part of an experiment
in community control.
They're all set up
for political reasons.
Some of them were designed
to keep all the white people
together.
Some of them were designed
to give Puerto Ricans
power in East Harlem.
Some of them were designed to
dilute African-American power.
Some of them were
designed to concentrate
African-American power.
The reason you need to
know about them today
is that your child is
guaranteed a seat in one
of these in the district
in which you live.
And some of the districts
are really first rate,
and some of them are not
ready for prime time.
One of you said that the--
whoops, I seemed to have
missed the Inside Schools.
All right, well, one of you
said that the Department
of Education website
is very hard to use.
We agree.
We at Inside Schools have
been working very hard
to develop a new website.
We have it in development now.
We plan to launch it
in the end of May.
And I'm hoping to get some
Google volunteers to help us
with a guided search
that will go through,
help parents answer a
certain number of questions.
I don't know what
happened to that slide,
but if you go to
insideschools.org,
you'll see our old slide.
And if you go to the--
ah here it is.
What we're hoping to
get is a guided search.
So instead of searching by
finding your zoned school
or finding schools
in your neighborhood,
we would also ask a
couple of questions
like how old is your child?
How far are you
willing to travel?
Are you interested in a
dual-language program?
For pre-kindergarten, do
you need care from 8:00
in the morning to 6:00
at night, or are you
able to pick up your
child after school?
That kind of guided
search we would
love to have some help
with from any of you.
We have a couple
of other projects
for volunteers,
which [INAUDIBLE] has
put on the Google Give.
The best school guides and
the Inside School guides
are projects of the
Center for New York City
Affairs at the New School.
We're not for profit,
and we rely on donations
to keep providing this
service to parents.
So if you'd like to help us
out by making a donation,
or buying the book, or
both, we'd be very grateful.
The New York City public schools
helped make my own children
the adults they are today,
intellectually curious, morally
grounded, ever-generous, and
able to get along with people
of all races and backgrounds.
We wrote this book
in the hopes that it
can help you have the same
experience with your children.
So I will answer questions now.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Could I just
go to the next slide?
OK, so I just wanted
to let you guys
know that Inside Schools,
as you mentioned,
they operate on a
shoestring budget,
and they have a few
interesting projects that I
put in for Google
Serve for June,
some engineering projects, some
marketing strategy projects.
Really if you want
to get involved,
I put a go link, Inside
Schools dash volunteer.
Check them out.
Also, as I mentioned,
they're a nonprofit,
so I put a go link
for donations.
There's also books
in the back if you're
interested in
reading Clara's book.
It's fascinating.
I also wanted you guys, if
anyone has questions, please
come up to the mic and ask.
I think we can spend
the rest of the time
on questions, because
I know you have a lot.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Thank you, Clara,
for coming here.
I have a quick
question about, I know
many parents, including my
wife actually, six years ago,
I believe, told me that
we should move to a place
where the school is 9 in 10.
I said, what is 9 in 10?
She said that Inside Schools
had the ranking system, 9 in 10,
and that's how we ended
up buying a house.
That was long, long ago.
Now my son is five years old.
So that was too much
planning towards the ranking.
It But I still don't
understand how the numbers go,
because that 9 in 10 became 6
in 10, then that became 8 in 10.
So I learned that it's
not really test scores.
And really, is it worth
giving that much weightage,
depending on how--
CLARA HEMPHILL: That's
a good question.
We don't rank schools.
It's our dread competitor,
greatschools.net.
The difference between
greatschools.net and us
is that we live in New York,
and we actually visit schools.
And we base our reviews
on our visits to schools.
Greatschools.net uses
two-year-old national data.
It's a national website,
and it's largely
based on test scores,
which is, as I said,
where a school has been and
not where a school is going.
I think test scores
are a rough--
we have test scores
on our website,
and I think they
are a rough measure
of the quality of a school.
If you have single digits of
children passing the tests,
that's a problem.
If you have 80% passing,
that's a good thing.
On our website, we draw the
data from the Department
of Ed surveys, which are given
to a million parents, teachers,
and children themselves
at the schools.
And the data that we
consider important,
aside from the test
scores, is attendance--
do most of the children show up?
Teacher attendance-- do most
of the teachers show up?
Teacher satisfaction--
do most of the teachers
like the principal,
respect the principals?
Do they work together as a team?
So those are some of
the-- we have that data
for every school in the city.
And we have qualitative reviews
for about 800 of the schools.
Does that help?
AUDIENCE: Yep, thanks.
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned you weren't
a big fan of gifted education.
I was just wondering if
you could expand on that.
Do you think the whole idea
is bad, or just the way
it's actually implemented?
CLARA HEMPHILL:
There are clearly
some children who
need gifted education,
as there are some
children who need
any kind of special education.
And in a room of Googlers,
there are probably
some very gifted
children, I would guess.
If your child is two standard
deviations from the mean,
he may need gifted education.
The problem is that
the tests are set up
on national norms,
not local norms.
So your child might
be two or three grade
levels-- you might
live in the Bronx,
and your child is two or three
grade levels ahead of the kids
in the Bronx.
But the city test
wouldn't recognize that.
So there's almost
no kids in the Bronx
who are considered eligible
for gifted education.
And I think the tests also
reflect socioeconomics
as much as they reflect
some kind of curiosity
or natural ability.
In more wealthy
neighborhoods, your child
may be two standard
deviations from the mean,
but everybody else is the
same in that neighborhood.
So that District 2 on the Upper
East Side is like Lake Wobegon.
Everybody's above average.
But that doesn't mean that
they all need gifted education.
I can always tell when I've
got a real one on the phone.
The parent says that the
child has taught himself
algebra at the age of three,
and he's having a little trouble
making friends.
And the parents desperately
want their children
to be invited to
birthday parties.
That's an example of
a child who I think
needs the gifted education.
Now, if we all had good
neighborhood schools,
there would be a
very, very small need
for gifted education.
Unfortunately, the quality
of schools is really uneven.
And gifted education is
a particularly good way
to get out of a nasty
neighborhood school
that you don't want
to send your child to.
The other problem with
the gifted education
is I think children
need to learn
that hard work is what
matter, and you're not
born with gifts as much.
I mean, you may be
born with gifts,
but what counts is
how hard you work.
And in these gifted
programs, there's
kind of a fear of falling.
There's a fear of failure.
Also I think the tests
measure a rather narrow range
of academic skills.
They don't test if
you're a great musician.
you're a great artist.
They don't test if
you're athletic.
you're particularly
good at making friends and
ending playground squabbles.
So I want my children to be
exposed to all of those things
and not just to kids who do
well on a particular test.
The other thing
is I think giving
the test to four-year-olds
is really too early.
I just think that the predictive
quality of these tests
is not that-- the tests
are not that accurate.
And the divide between
the 99th percentile
and the 98th percentile
of kids at the age of four
is kind of ludicrous.
The other thing is
a lot of what you're
learning in elementary
school is not cognitive.
It's how to tie your shoes,
how to sit in a circle,
how to make friends,
how to get along
with the classroom routines.
So this is what I think about
early childhood education.
I think by third, fourth,
fifth, sixth grade,
a very good teacher can
reach a range of children.
But the wider that
range is, the harder it
is for a teacher to reach that.
In my kindergarten,
what you'd want
to ask of the school is, how
do you challenge children
at the top, and how do you
give help to kids who need it?
And your child might
need both, right?
Your child might be a math whiz
who has trouble making friends.
Or your child may be reading
"Harry Potter" in kindergarten
but can't add, right?
So your child can be
simultaneously gifted
and struggling at the same time.
My son was very good at puzzles.
And when in kindergarten he
finished the 100-piece puzzle,
the teacher would pull down
the 500-piece puzzle for him.
When you look in classrooms, you
want to see a range of books.
If everybody is
reading the same book,
that's probably
not a good place.
But if some kids are reading
"Frog and Toad" and other kids
are reading "Charlotte's
Web," that's a sign.
If you look at the
writing on the board
and you see some kids
are writing five pages
and some kids are
writing three paragraphs,
that's a sign that
the school is adapting
to kids with different needs.
So of course you want your
child to be challenged
if he's very bright,
and you want him
to get the help if he needs it.
But that doesn't
necessarily mean
he needs to be
segregated in a classroom
with other kids who do
well on this academic test.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So the school that we're
zoned for is relatively new.
It was just launched like
four years ago, maybe,
so I think there's not a lot
of information on it yet.
CLARA HEMPHILL: Which school?
AUDIENCE: It's the School
for Social Action--
CLARA HEMPHILL: Yeah, I know it.
AUDIENCE: --527, I think it is.
So we ideally want to send-- our
daughter is only 7 months old.
But we want to send
her there, but we're
being told by a lot of people
to keep our options open
and make sure we're
planning for the possibility
of a gifted and talented
program or a private school.
So I guess my
question is twofold.
What are your thoughts
on that and knowing
that our daughter's so young?
What are the things
that we should
be thinking about
right now to set her up
for whatever options?
But ideally wanting to
send her to public school,
are there things that we should
be thinking about doing now?
CLARA HEMPHILL: If you can
afford to stay in District 2,
I'd stay put.
District 2 not only has
terrific elementary schools.
It also has good middle
schools and good high schools,
which is not universally
the case at all.
Then I like 527 a lot.
It's a shade more
traditional than some-- well,
I won't get into details
about individual schools.
But in your
district, I like 527.
It's in the book.
You can read about it.
There's also a gifted
program a few blocks away.
There's two gifted programs a
few blocks away, both of which
I like very well.
AUDIENCE: So are
there things we should
be thinking about doing,
though, to make sure
that she's prepared
for the application
process for gifted and
talented or for getting her
ready for elementary school?
Because I've just heard from
people in the building who
are saying they send their
kids to gifted and talented,
and they're like, oh there's
all these things you have to do,
these classes you have
to take to make sure
that they're on the
resume for a two-year-old.
CLARA HEMPHILL: Yeah, I
think it's kind of sick.
I want to let children
be children, right?
AUDIENCE: I agree.
CLARA HEMPHILL: And I will
encourage you to resist that.
My son, I thought he was gifted.
You know, he was doing the
big puzzles in kindergarten.
But at the age of four, he
was still throwing blocks.
And the thought of
having him sit down
with a stranger and a pencil and
paper test just seemed insane.
So yeah, sure,
there are people who
will charge you lots of money
to prepare for this test.
But I would strongly
discourage it, particularly
because you live
in a neighborhood
where the zoned
schools are fine.
In neighborhoods where the
zoned schools are not fine--
I don't mean to trash gifted
and talented across the board.
Easy for me to say.
My kids went to the local
school, and it was great.
For a lot of people, the gifted
schools are a good option.
AUDIENCE: Sorry,
one last thing then.
If the baby-- you mentioned
that the cutoff is December 31.
There's a lot of theories
about keeping your child back
or advancing them.
But it sounds like
my reading showed me
that in public schools you
don't really have that choice.
Is that true, or can you
hold your child back?
CLARA HEMPHILL: You cannot.
AUDIENCE: OK.
CLARA HEMPHILL: You're
stuck with the--
AUDIENCE: Starting at four.
CLARA HEMPHILL: Yeah, so this
is called redshirting, where
you hold the kids back a yeah,
with the idea that they'll
be bigger and
stronger and smarter.
And it's the same
group of people
who are telling
you to get the test
prep for your seven-month-old.
AUDIENCE: It is.
CLARA HEMPHILL: I have
a November birthday,
so my daughter was
the November birthday.
And she was pretty
tiny for kindergarten,
and she was pretty exhausted
at the end of the day.
So I understand the--
AUDIENCE: Theory?
CLARA HEMPHILL: Yeah, I
understand the impulse to--
I mean, I think it's actually
there are political reasons why
these things are set up
that don't necessarily
have to do with pedagogy
or child development.
I hope the question you could
ask at 527 or any other school
is, my child has a
November birthday.
How do you adapt for
younger children?
You know, do they
have a rest time?
Can they accommodate a child
who's a little bit younger?
And see what they answer.
I mean, I think that's
a valid question.
But they won't let you
redshirt them, unfortunately.
AUDIENCE: We don't
have an option, OK.
All right, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
CLARA HEMPHILL: Hi.
AUDIENCE: A couple of
questions, if I may.
First, I'd love to hear your
thoughts on non-zoned district
schools.
Why do they exist,
and what steps
can one take if there's
a great one nearby
that you want to
get your kid into?
And then second, the
school in my zone
appears to not be a good school.
I haven't looked.
I'm going to buy your book
because you've convinced me.
But I've looked
at School Digger,
and the ranks aren't good.
CLARA HEMPHILL:
What's the school?
AUDIENCE: Alfred Aux.
CLARA HEMPHILL: OK, I
know that school, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I mean,
my kids are four.
They're already signed
up for preschool,
but I'm thinking about
kindergarten for years
down the road.
Realistically, are
there things that I
can do as a parent who wants
to be involved to really make
an impact on the school nearby?
Or is my time better
spent thinking about
how I can get my kids
into a different school,
whether that's the non-zoned
district school, or moving,
or something else?
CLARA HEMPHILL: I
love that question.
That's a really good one.
Yes parents can
make a difference.
You have to talk
to other parents
and see if you've got other
people who can work with you.
And then you have to
talk to the principal
and see if he wants you to work.
And you can't say,
this a terrible school.
We're going to save
you and make it better.
For some reason, that approach
is not really welcomed.
AUDIENCE: I don't know why.
CLARA HEMPHILL: But, you
know, we love the school
and we want to support it.
Can we do x, y, z?
So some of the districts have
district-wide school choice.
So again, this is
Hell's Kitchen.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, 212 is right by.
CLARA HEMPHILL:
Yeah, and there's
Midtown West, which is a
school that accepts kids
from all over the district,
and supposedly by lottery.
Same as-- I don't know if you
read the piece in the Sunday
"Times" about 165 and
Manhattan School for Children
on the Upper West
Side, another case
of a sort of
unfavored zoned school
and a favored cool,
groovy, boutique, hipster,
millennium school.
And how they got
set up was parents
who were zoned for
the unfavored school
were dissatisfied and
created something new
under the auspices of
the Department of Ed.
And these district schools
used to have their thumb
on the scales for parents
who wanted to volunteer.
The last administration,
Bloomberg
thought that was
not really fair.
I think there was one--
Joel Klein, the
previous chancellor,
may have read in my
book where I said
one family had two mothers,
and they promised two mothers
in the PTA, and that got
them into the school.
And the school's
chancellor thought
this kind of string pulling
was really not very nice.
So he made it everything's
done by lottery now.
However, after the first
round of admissions comes out,
the admissions reverts
to the local school.
And at that point,
pleasant persistence
can make a difference.
111, your school, I
didn't put it in the book,
but it's moving in
the right direction.
So I would give
it another visit.
And I also want to encourage
you to go to insideschools.org
and not School Digger
and, you know--
AUDIENCE: Will do.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks
for coming today.
We're a big fan of your
books and your site.
CLARA HEMPHILL: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Just a
general question.
What's a trend that you
like in public schools,
and what's a trend you're
not so happy about?
CLARA HEMPHILL:
Oh, well, I think
pre-K is wonderful, right?
I mean, I paid $12,000
for nursery school
when my kids were little.
So I think that's
a wonderful trend.
I think the trend towards
progressive education
is a good one.
I think children
learn through doing.
They learn through play.
They learn by putting
together blocks.
They learn engineering and math
skills with blocks and Lego.
So I like classrooms that
have a lot of blocks and Lego,
rather than classrooms
for the little kids
that have lots of pencil
and paper exercises.
I like schools where
the children read what
they call authentic literature.
That is children's
picture books and books
that you might read for fun.
I think the extent to
which that's increasing.
I think is a very good idea.
What I don't like
is the obsession
with standardized tests.
Some schools have become
just test prep hell
where the kids work for
hours and hours and hours
learning how to fill
out bubble sheets.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have maybe two
questions, if there's time,
about reading between
the lines on a school.
One question is,
how do you determine
if a school is improving?
Because you mentioned
how it's not about
where the school has been.
CLARA HEMPHILL: That's
a really good question.
In terms of data, I look to see
if enrollment is increasing.
That's usually a sign of
parents voting with their feet.
I look to see if
attendance is improving.
Before the test scores
go up, you've got to--
some of the public schools
have very, very high rates
of absenteeism.
And that's a sign
that the kids are not
happy to be there,
and so when you
see the attendance going up.
The most important thing
is an effective principal,
hands down.
A good principal will
attract good teachers
and encourage them to
work together as a team.
A bad principal can dismantle
a good school just as quickly.
So leadership is all, and you
can usually feel the difference
within about a couple of weeks
of the new principal coming
to town.
So in terms of the data, we do
look at teacher satisfaction
with the principal is
one thing to look at,
which we have on our website.
And those are the
signs that a school is
moving in the right direction.
Again, schools
that are improving
start getting better
in the lower grades
and build up one by one.
So if you see a good
pre-K and kindergarten
but the fifth grade is not
so hot, that may be OK.
It could be that they're
building from the bottom up.
So look for the lower grades.
Is that helpful?
AUDIENCE: That was great.
Another quick question then.
So speaking of someone
who would be parents
of mixed-race children,
I'm thinking of,
how could you determine if
there's the educational quality
available for all children?
Because sometimes some
schools we looked at
we'd think some anxiety if, oh,
their rating on School Crusher
or whatever--
their rating on some
other website is high,
but then they see like really
significant segregation
at the gas levels
of other things.
So how could you read into
whether it's a good education
for all of the students there?
CLARA HEMPHILL: Yeah, I
talk to parents about that.
It's funny.
I went to PS 75, which
was one of my slides,
with an African-American
staff member, and 166.
75 is mostly black and Latino,
and 166 is mostly white.
And she felt right
away a different vibe
in the building
about how welcoming
they are to people of color.
But a lot of the schools
that are multi-racial do
have lots of
multi-racial families
also, because for them
it's very important.
You know, if you have a black
mother and a white father,
you may not want your child
in an all black school,
but you don't want your child
in an all white school either.
So I would ask for the parents.
I should have brought--
I'll send you a link to our
report on integrated schools
that work, which is on the
Center for New York City
Affairs website.
And one of the things
that really matters
is that the principal wants
the school to be integrated.
You'd be surprised at
the number of principals
who really don't care and are
happy with whatever the status
quo is.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm in the middle of
going through the process
with my four-year-old.
So I was just wondering if
you had any more insight
or could explain more about
the wait list situation
and how that movement works.
Because being in
May now, and we're
on the wait list at
five different programs.
CLARA HEMPHILL: Wait list
at five different programs
for pre-K, or for--
AUDIENCE: For pre-K,
and our wait lists,
when I call the schools,
we're like 114 on the list
and number 42 on the list.
And--
CLARA HEMPHILL: For pre-K
you're talking about.
AUDIENCE: For pre-K.
CLARA HEMPHILL: Yeah,
when I was being
blase about the wait lists, I
was talking about kindergarten.
AUDIENCE: OK.
CLARA HEMPHILL: Pre-K it's a
whole different kettle of fish.
You might have 18 seats and
500 kids, applying, so--
AUDIENCE: So those
lists don't move then.
CLARA HEMPHILL: They don't--
let's talk afterwards
a little bit
about your particular situation.
AUDIENCE: And then how
do you manage between--
so because pre-K is so
different than kindergarten,
my understanding from
everyone I hear that is you
have to go through this all
over again for kindergarten.
CLARA HEMPHILL: Isn't it awful?
Do you believe it?
Yeah, and then middle
school and high school too.
AUDIENCE: So how
do you even plan
what pre-K you would want
to go to for consistency's
sake for your kid?
CLARA HEMPHILL: I mean,
consistency is nice.
It would be great.
AUDIENCE: So you just--
it's not realistic.
CLARA HEMPHILL:
I talk to parents
who have private nursery
school for the three-year-old
and then public pre-K
for the four-year-old
and then a public school
for when he's five.
And moving three times in three
years would drive me nuts.
So I can understand--
I think continuity
is probably worth
spending a little money for if
you have to, but more for you
than for your child.
I mean, I think your child
will probably adjust.
The pre-K situation, it's only
been around for two years.
They created 70,000 seats
practically overnight.
That it's functioning
is a miracle.
But certain
neighborhoods this city,
there are just long wait lists.
And they haven't
figured it out yet.
AUDIENCE: It's shocking.
But thank you.
CLARA HEMPHILL: Yeah, sorry.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you
said several times,
the principal's the
most important thing.
And you said, the principal
can make it happen.
The school across
the street from us--
it's PS 38, the
Pacific in Brooklyn--
all the comments
talk about trouble
with the administration and
the principal not being good.
Is there something that you can
do about that, or is it just
you avoid the school,
or I don't know--
CLARA HEMPHILL:
Parents can lobby
to get rid of a principal.
They succeeded at 282,
which is in Park Slope,
not too far from you.
At 38, they're trying to
work around the principal.
There are a couple
of schools that
managed to build
a cohesive staff
despite an inadequate principal.
But then you have
to figure out why--
some parents have also gotten
rid of terrible district
superintendents.
In Washington Heights,
parents united to get rid of.
So, yeah, get rid of or work
around are the two answers.
AUDIENCE: Does
working around work?
Would you think that
school can be functional,
or is it really it's
kind of in trouble
with a principle like that?
CLARA HEMPHILL: I think you
should talk to the parents who
are there every day.
I agree with your assessment.
That said, there
are some parents
who are very happy
with the situation.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to
go back a little bit
to the gifted and very high
functioning district school
question.
So I went to a public magnet
school that was amazing,
and it was a really
good experience, very
along the lines of Stuyvesant.
And where I came from,
there was definitely
a concept of feeder
schools, that there
were middle schools
that gave rise
to most of the high
schools, and there
were elementary
schools that gave rise
to most of the middle schools.
Is there a feeder
school style setup
here for the high schools?
CLARA HEMPHILL: Alas, yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
CLARA HEMPHILL: Another
one of our reports
on the Center for New
York City Affairs website
shows you what middle school
feeders there are to Stuyvesant
and Brooklyn Tech and the
specialized high schools.
So yes, but you don't have
to worry in kindergarten.
AUDIENCE: OK.
CLARA HEMPHILL: I think.
AUDIENCE: But I
guess do they tend
to be the sort of really
good neighborhood schools,
or do they tend to be gifted
schools, or is it a mix?
CLARA HEMPHILL: Don't worry
about it in elementary.
AUDIENCE: OK.
CLARA HEMPHILL: You know,
call me in five years,
and we'll work it out.
I'm not pretending the system
is equitable and works well
for everybody.
AUDIENCE: OK.
CLARA HEMPHILL: We have
three more minutes, I guess.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK, so I
grew up in Europe,
and I'm a lot more familiar
with the school systems there.
A lot of things
are different here.
Two things that we
haven't really touched on.
One of them was that we learned
that classes get new teachers
every year instead of
one teacher taking them
throughout the first
five years of school.
Is that true across the
board in most public schools,
or are there differences,
or what's your opinion?
CLARA HEMPHILL:
Some schools have
what they call looping, which is
I teach kindergarten this year
and first grade next
year, and then I
go back to kindergarten
and then first grade.
So you have the same
teacher for two years.
And if you put looping
into our search engine,
you might find some
schools like that.
Or in the book you can see some.
The other thing that
a few schools have
is what they call
bridge classes, where
you have both kindergarten and
first grade in one classroom,
and you stay in that classroom
with the same teacher for two
years.
So we do have some of that.
Rudolf Steiner
School is private.
It's the only one I
know of that keeps
the kids for the whole of
their elementary school.
The New American Academy might
do that as well in Brooklyn.
I think they may have
that European model.
AUDIENCE: But you don't
think there's value in that,
or it's just not common, or--
CLARA HEMPHILL: Oh, sure, I
mean, like any of these things,
there's advantages
and drawbacks.
AUDIENCE: And the other
thing I wanted to touch on
is about the PTA,
where people ask
how they can get involved and
do something for the school.
I sort of want to
ask the opposite.
In Europe, schools work, and you
can get involved a little bit.
But I sometimes feel there
is an expectation or pressure
for people to get involved.
And even though this isn't
like a private preschool,
that parents who don't get
involved are called out,
or it's like--
I'm wondering how this happens.
CLARA HEMPHILL:
This, I think it's--
I mean, the other difference
between the United States
and Europe is that
our schools are
supported through local
taxes, mostly property taxes.
And in most countries
of the world,
it's a national system
where all the teachers
get the same pay and the schools
all get the same resources.
So what we do in
New York City is
we have these insane PTAs that
raise a million dollars a year.
I agree with you
that it's lunacy.
Some schools will pressure you.
Some actually have a kind of
parents stay out attitude.
So it varies from
school to school.
AUDIENCE: Yep.
CLARA HEMPHILL: Yeah, I
mean, I agree with you.
It's ridiculous.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: What are your thoughts
on dual-language programs
and how effective they are for
native speakers of English?
CLARA HEMPHILL:
Very good question,
so in the index of
the book, you'll
find dual-language programs.
There's Chinese, Spanish,
Polish, Italian, Haitian
Creole, French, Mandarin.
There's even one
in Korean as well.
And the way they're
supposed to be designed
is half the children speak
English at home, half of them
speak the other language, and
they alternate the language
of instruction from day to day.
And the kids are supposed to
be fluent in both languages
by the time they're
in fifth grade.
Some of them work
very well indeed.
It also depends on the language.
I think Chinese
and Korean are very
hard for non-native
speakers to learn just
in that six hours a day.
Some of the successful
Chinese dual-language programs
continue until 5 o'clock
in the afternoon,
particularly for writing.
That's difficult.
For Spanish, I think
non-native speakers
come out doing pretty well.
And there's also,
like everything else,
there's a range of quality.
Some of them it's just
sort of a little smattering
in the language.
You'll learn to sing some songs.
Others are you really learn
to write and spell and speak
about science in
the second language.
So there's a range there.
So it's 1 o'clock.
I think we have to wrap up.
So thank you so much for coming.
[APPLAUSE]